- Hi, everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the the Homeroom livestream.
You might notice I've
upgraded my equipment
at Philippe's request.
And so this is like now in HD.
So this is a very,
very, very exciting day.
So we have a very exciting guest today.
We have Mayim Bialik,
who is an actress, a neuroscientist,
now an author and a podcast creator,
and we'll talk a lot about that.
But before we jump into that conversation,
I will give my standard announcements.
A reminder that we are,
Khan Academy is a not-for-profit.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate
and making a donation.
I want to also give a special shout out
to several organizations that stepped up,
especially when they realized
that during the pandemic
more people than ever were
relying on Khan Academy.
And that's awesome,
but it was also driving our costs up,
our server costs.
We wanted to accelerate
a bunch of content.
So special thanks to Bank of
America, AT&T, Google.org,
Novartis, Fastly and General Motors,
And last but not least,
I want to give everyone a reminder
that there's a version of this livestream
that is available in podcast form
wherever you get your podcasts.
Homeroom with Sal The Podcast.
So with that, I am very
excited to introduce Mayim.
Mayim, welcome.
- Thank you, I hope I'm
not late to homeroom.
- You're not.
We need to get a bell so that people like,
you know, they're in
mentally the right place.
So there's so much that we can chat about,
I'm trying to level it
so that our shoulders
are on the same level.
- I appreciated it.
I felt like I was looking down at you.
- Which you can do.
So there's so much to talk about.
We've gotten to know each
other virtually over several,
we were on a panel together
a couple of months ago
and then I was on your podcast yesterday
and there's a lot of stuff to overlap,
but I did tell you when I first met you
and I'm not normally like into
this whole celebrity thing,
but there's something about
growing up watching "Blossom",
and I know you've done other
things in your life since then
and you've gotten Phd's,
you're a neuroscientist,
but as I said yesterday,
I try to play it cool when I'm around you.
- Well I think I told
you the first time we met
when we were on that panel together,
you are the celebrity to me.
My kids have been using
Khan Academy for years
and it's an enormously
important part of our lives
and when I told my kids
that I was gonna be on a panel with you,
we all freaked out.
So it is really my honor
to be in Homeroom with you.
- Well sounds like a win-win then.
Well, there's so much to talk about
and I encourage anyone watching
to put your questions in.
We have team members who
can surface the questions
to myself and Mayim.
But you have an eclectic background.
There are not a lot of
neuroscientist author
actresses in the world.
How do you identify?
Do you connect with all
of those identities?
Are you more one than the other?
Did you think you would
have this hodgepodge
of things to do?
- No, I mean I identify as
the grandchild of immigrants.
Like when I think of who I am,
you know, my grandparents
came to this country
during the pogroms leading
up to the Holocaust.
So that's, I'm my parent's daughter
and I'm my grandparent's grandchild
and everything that happened
once they hit Ellis Island
is really my story.
Everybody's got a story.
For me, I was raised in a very colorful
first-generation American household
and my native language is Yiddish,
that's the language of
Eastern European Jews.
I was raised really
spanning several cultures
and I was a very
problem-solving kind of child
and I felt very comfortable on a stage
and I became an actor, you
know, as a young person,
but truly I'm a thinker
and I found math and science late in life
and fought really hard to
be able to be a scientist.
When it doesn't come naturally to you
and you're told that if
it doesn't come naturally,
it's not for you,
it's very hard to try and
break into that at 15 and 16,
which is what I did.
So I became a neuroscientist.
It took, you know, 12 years
between undergrad and grad school
and I had my first son in grad school.
He's now 15 and I have a 12 year old.
So I'm a mom,
like that's really what
my life is, I'm a mom.
And yes, I have written books,
I do a lot of things,
not to make ends meet,
but to sort of satisfy
the different parts of my
brain and my life and yeah,
I guess I'm all of those hyphenates.
I'm also a lactation educator counselor.
I've been that for about 13 years.
And so I speak to women about
breastfeeding and labor,
like I do a lot of different things
'cause I just feel like
that's my human experience.
- Well, it's fascinating.
So I mean take us on your
journey a little bit.
You know, a lot of people
watching are young people
trying to figure out what
to do with their lives.
You at a very young age,
I mean how did you get into acting?
Was your family into it?
- No, my parents were
public school teachers
and documentary filmmakers.
My parents were both English teachers.
My mother was a preschool
early childhood educator.
I didn't grow up in a Hollywood house.
I grew up in kind of a crummy
rental house in Hollywood
and was part of the busing
program of the '70s and '80s
that took kids from rougher neighborhoods
and took us to neighborhoods
where there were more
educational opportunities.
So I grew up just like a normal kid
just living with parents
who were teachers.
And I was in school plays
in elementary school
and really liked it,
felt safe on a stage.
I wasn't one of those
like super hammy kids,
like look at me, I'm amazing,
like I didn't think that
I just knew that there was
a safety for me that I felt
honestly when making other people happy.
And there's a very interesting psychology
to why some actors really do act
because we want other
people to feel something.
And that was kind of
what it was like for me.
And I knew that there were kid actors.
It didn't occur to me that
no one looked like me in 1986
and that maybe I wouldn't have success.
I indeed did not have success
in traditional things that
kid actors do like commercials
because back then there was
something called all American
and I didn't look like it.
- So how did you fall into that?
Did someone just discover you?
Was there an ad you read?
- No, it's literally like
the 1986 story is that
my parents typed a letter on a typewriter
and took a picture of me
like just in the backyard, a cute headshot
and they mailed it.
There was no computers that we had then.
There wasn't anything to email.
They looked in the yellow pages
and just found kids agents
and literally sent my
picture and this letter
to nine different kids agents.
And I ended up picking an agent
who happened to have a lot,
quite famous kids have
come out of her agency,
Neil Patrick Harris and Johnny Galecki,
who I was with on "The Big Bang Theory"
and Mario Lopez was with her.
So I ended up just going on auditions
and I was in a lot of
sitcoms from the '80s,
things like "Webster",
"MacGyver", "Facts of Life".
And then I was cast to
play the young Bette Midler
in "Beaches" when I was 12
and it came out when I was 13.
And then after that, I did
"Blossom" from 14 to 19.
- I have to find these clips.
You've just like,
my entire childhood just came
back to me in that one answer.
- I mean my head didn't change size.
I had this enormous head,
I had a little twig body
and then I just sort of grew into my head.
- I have a similar experience.
Actually, I'm I'm three
inches taller than my wife
but our shoulders are at the same height.
So I'm all head and I've always been.
And I see it in my children,
like when they're born,
they can't touch the top of their heads
because their heads are
the same size as mine.
But your parents,
they must've seen something
in you at that age
to kind of go through the
trouble of taking your headshot
and sending it in.
- Yeah I think, look,
I was raised in a traditional Jewish house
and there is a lot of performance
to a lot of aspects of our culture,
meaning when we read the Torah,
which is the Old Testament, it's chanted
and a bar mitzvah's a very presentational,
we sing our Bible, like
we are a presentation,
Passover involves reciting
the four questions
and being able to do that.
So I definitely had a lot of opportunities
and I was in dance as a lot of
young kids are, young girls.
So I was a ballerina
from the time I was four,
I was in classical English
ballet and I danced
and sure I was charismatic,
but I think a lot of
parents think their kids
are cute and charismatic.
I don't know,
they said they always
felt like I had something
but I really don't know.
'Cause like my mom still is like
"You're prettier than
any woman in the world."
And it's like, I know that's not true
so you don't know if you
can trust your parents.
- And what was it like?
I mean there's this
stereotype of people who,
child actors, they hit
notoriety early in their lives,
maybe their identity gets caught up in it
and you're kind of clinging onto it
and life throws interesting things at you.
How did you deal?
Were you conscientious of that
when you were 10, 11, 12, 13 years old?
- Yeah I mean because I come from,
at least for us,
I come from an immigrant mentality
where like you go to
school, you get an education
and I always had this notion
that like everything is fleeting,
the success is fleeting, like everything.
It's a very Zen Buddhist philosophy,
this too shall pass.
And so my education was
very important to me.
It was very important to my
parents who were both teachers.
They didn't want me being on a set
for many months of the year
to take the place of the
education that I still needed.
So they went to a lot of work.
There was a woman named Janie Teller
who was in charge of my education
and hired me different
tutors for every subject
and got me some incredible
really amazing tutors,
especially for my science subjects.
And that's how I fell
in love with science.
So I really, I was never really taken
with like the fame and the
money parts of show business.
I was raised as a kind
of small intellectual.
That's just how my dad
and my mom raised me.
So I knew I wanted to be around people
who were thinking deeply
and while there are many
intelligent people in the industry,
I really thrived in a
public university system.
I went to UCLA and yes,
it was intimidating
to be in large classes,
for a lot of our core classes,
we were often with 300
people in the class,
but I made most of the
you're then divided into sections
and I made use of office hours
and I loved that environment.
I'm a very organized person
when it comes to schoolwork.
So everything was color coded
and my assignment notebooks
and all those things
and I really just, I wanted
more of a normal life
than I think the industry
could provide me with.
- And there's questions,
a ton of questions are coming in
off of YouTube and Facebook
and this is related.
Crystal Gross writes from YouTube,
"What is your advice for kids
who want to become scientists
or have careers in math
but they struggle with
courses geared towards that?
They have the dream, but not the grades."
And you had mentioned,
and you just mentioned
that at least initially you
were struggling a little bit
or maybe you felt a little
bit of an imposter syndrome.
How do you navigate that?
- I think part of it is,
there's two components for me.
There's two components.
One was the skill set and
the other was the confidence.
And for me, kind of the
confidence had to come first,
meaning believing that I had the right
to learn these kinds of subjects
and that there's not just
one way to learn them.
So for me, working with a
tutor was extremely helpful,
having more of an intimate
kind of one-on-one experience
was a real help for me.
In the time that I grew up,
there were not a lot of women in STEM,
at least in ways that I had access to.
So having a female tutor
was also very empowering
because I could see someone
else who had been working at it.
She was 19 when I met her
and I was like, yeah, 15,
but you know, she was in college
and she came from a family,
an immigrant family from Iran
and education was very
important to her family
and all her sisters got to go
to either med school or dental school.
So she's now an oral surgeon,
but having that relationship
where someone was teaching
me the way I learned
was really helpful.
And I think also
the pacing of how classes
were traditionally taught
didn't always work for
me in those subjects.
You know, English I could get like that,
like that wasn't a problem,
sociology, anthropology, psychology,
all that stuff, that wasn't the issue.
Numbers and formulas was hard for me
at the pacing that things were set at.
So I did need to work harder.
And honestly, I had to work harder
all the way through my undergrad
and an all the way into grad school,
meaning there were certain things
that came a lot easier to me,
but I worked in a genetics lab,
conversions were always hard for me,
even working in a genetics lab.
So there were still things that
I had to always keep up on.
- And what was it,
what was the moment that
you said, neuroscience,
I want to be a neuroscientist,
even though it might have some of these
speed bumps along the way
that you might not have felt
are like your, wasn't the
easiest thing for you?
- So the first thing
that really kind of
captivated me in science
was really cell biology, DNA,
like once I got to understand
and like once it clicked,
like, oh, it's this and then
the histones and the things,
I hope that's still true,
I mean I haven't studied DNA.
- It is true.
I think histones are still
part of the packaging of DNA.
- Proteins, yeah.
So I was interested in
nature versus nurture,
which was a popular,
kind of a popular science
topic in the '90s,
like what makes us who we are?
I know for young people, it's like, duh,
but back then there was a
lot of discussion about it.
And the God's honest truth
is that I wanted to study
biology when I got to UCLA,
but because my calculus and my chemistry
were not at an appropriately high level
I had to take really remedial,
I mean it was remedial
chemistry and remedial calculus.
And so until I did those things
I couldn't register for biology.
So I was so frustrated,
I was so embarrassed
that like here I was
wanting to be a scientist
and I couldn't even start
the core curriculum,
but one of the classes that didn't require
my chemistry and calculus to be completed
was a class called Psychobiology.
And the first half of the class
was taught by a psychology professor
who specialized in things
like conditioned response,
like Pavlovian stuff,
very interesting, very important,
attachment theory, great.
The second half of the course
was taught by Professor Iran Zidell
and he was in the psychology department
but he taught the neurophysiology
of the nervous system,
and in particular electrophysiology.
And when I saw, this is my moment,
when I saw that action potential chart
and I saw that electrical impulses
are what allow for the release
of sodium and potassium
and all of these ions
that lead to a chain reaction
that caused further electrical responses
and that's how we perceive the world,
I literally said, "That's the level.
I want to understand the
universe at that, that level."
And that is when I decided
to become a neuroscientist.
- I am so excited to hear you say that.
I think we're gonna take that
clip of what you just said
and on Khan Academy where we introduce
action potential sodium potassium pump-
- I will teach that class with joy.
I've done it before,
I would love to.
- And even just your answer right now.
The number one thing is people,
I always tell folks
that you get to learn
all of this stuff that,
what's in the textbook
is hundreds of years of human knowledge
and the people who dedicated their lives
to discovering what's in the textbook
would have killed to have that textbook.
But so many kids are
like, "Ugh, I got to learn
about the sodium potassium pump."
But when they hear you out of all of what,
you were on "MacGyver",
that sounds exciting
but I heard more excitement in your voice
about the sodium potassium and
action potentials in neurons
than "MacGyver".
- Well, and also, I had the opportunity,
I taught neuroscience,
I designed a curriculum
for junior high and high school students
in our homeschool community
and I taught for about five years,
before "Big Bang Theory,
I taught in our community.
And to be able to be
a science communicator
is a very special,
and you know, obviously,
it's one thing to know the material
but to be either gifted or taught
the skills to communicate
it to other people
and to explain it until
you see that they get it,
it is an exceptional,
it's an exceptional moment of
like a microcosm of creation.
You're creating an inspired thought
in someone who previously
didn't understand it.
And when I think of the concepts
that were hardest for me,
I remember learning the optical system
and the way the ganglion neurons
and the amacrine neurons and
all those things line up,
it is so difficult
and how it's like a
constantly generating system
that needs to have a
negative feedback loop
and I remember how hard it was,
but when you get it,
that feeling, it's better than applause,
it's better than an Emmy.
I've never won an Emmy,
I've only been nominated four times,
but that satisfaction
of the human mind grasping
something of that enormity
there literally is nothing like it.
I mean giving birth was
enormously significant
but it's on that level of like wow.
- Well, no, you've made
me feel better 'cause I,
I haven't given birth,
I've modeled it in my mind,
but I have had that
experience which you have
which is when something clicks
and you understand the
universe in another way
like that is what it means to be human,
that is what it means to experience life.
- Absolutely.
- And I know you might be
saying that you would love to teach,
we will talk later.
We're doing a big push on
science on Khan Academy.
- You know where to find me.
- I know where to find you for sure.
So all sorts of questions coming in.
Actually before I get to a
more questions, I am curious,
when you were at UCLA or into grad school
and you're learning the neuroscience,
you're thinking about
becoming a neuroscientist,
was in the back of your mind,
like education's important,
it's a safety net,
that's my backup
in case Hollywood isn't
what what I hope it could be
or was it the other way around
like no I want to be a neuroscientist
and on the side, I'll
do a couple of cameos
or be in a couple of shoes here in there.
- No, when I left the industry,
I was 19, I was two
years out of high school.
I went to a very college prep style,
honestly junior high and high
school here in Los Angeles
and I was geared to go to college.
And to be honest, when
I left the industry,
I didn't have active
plans to return to it.
I wanted to live in an apartment
and walk to campus and
meet other students.
I was very active in the
Jewish Student Union.
I studied Japanese history
and I studied philosophy,
like I had the best time there
and I met the person that I
then married and had children.
We met in calculus class.
Like I was living a
totally different life.
I would go to school in pajamas
like most science students did
like I loved my life.
And I originally wanted
to go to med school.
I wanted to study psychiatry,
God's honest truth, I could
not get higher than a B minus
in organic chemistry
'cause that really was the
weeder class for med school
and I hate to say those
who can't go to med school,
go to grad school, but I did,
I made the decision to be a
more of a research academic.
I was not planning on
going back to the industry.
Like I said I taught after
getting my doctorate.
Acting is a very interesting world,
but it's not intellectually stimulating
the way being a scientist was.
And to be perfectly honest,
you know, having my first son,
which I did after my data
collection for my thesis project
and I essentially wrote my thesis
while laying down breastfeeding,
it was the decision to leave academia
because I was choosing
to be home with my son
that actually shifted kind
of the trajectory of my life.
And that's a very difficult decision.
I can't say it was the
right decision for everyone,
but for me it was the decision,
and for my husband at the time.
that was the decision we made.
And so I tutored
and I also taught piano,
I taught Hebrew,
I did a lot of things while
also being the primary caregiver
for my son
and then had another one right
after I got my doctorate.
So my life really shifted in
terms of the academic track,
but I was still teaching.
And because of the United
States healthcare system,
I did return to acting to
literally do enough work
so that I could get my insurance back
through Screen Actors Guild,
which is excellent insurance.
- Really, you acted for insurance?
That's the most pragmatic
reason I've ever heard.
- Well and someone said,
we literally got Mayim
on the "Big Bang Theory"
because of the failure
of our healthcare system.
- Y'all must have better
healthcare than I imagined
at the Screen Actors Guild.
That's good, I'm happy to hear that.
Talking to you is fascinating
because I listed three things,
author, actress, neuroscientist,
but clearly mother,
very important, very
large role of your life.
Now you are also doing this
podcast, "Bialik Breakdown",
which is about mental health.
You are this polymath type person,
you're taking on a lot
of different projects.
Why the podcast now and why
this focus on mental health?
- You know, my interest
has really always hovered
around mental health challenges.
I grew up in a home
that had mental illness,
as many homes do.
And I think many families have it
but we don't really call it that
or even when I listen to stories
of my grandparent's generation,
oh this one was like, and it's
like, that was schizophrenia.
You know, we didn't know to call it that
but someone who hears voices,
like that's actually a
clinical diagnosis, you know?
So I have always had an interest
in the way we react to those environments
and what's genetic and
what's environmental.
I do have my share of challenges
and I've been very open about it,
but it was really last year
when the world got very
small in many ways,
as many of us were home,
that so many people that I
knew started experiencing
in particular anxiety and panic
and they honestly didn't
even know what to call it.
And I was thinking how many people
are experiencing challenges
that are lacking just
the basic information
about what's going on.
So my partner, Jonathan and I,
we started a "Mayim Bialik's Breakdown"
really to start breaking
down some of the terms
and some of the misconceptions also
that people have about mental health.
And this isn't like
I've figured it all out,
come and listen
how I'm gonna tell you
to make your life better.
This is I still live with anxiety,
I have struggled with depression,
I am on the OCD spectrum.
Those are just true things about me.
And I still get to figure out
what works and what doesn't.
And the notion of mind body syndrome
and the things that Eastern
medicine and Eastern cultures
have known about for thousands of years
that we're finally catching onto
is also something that
that Jonathan are looking to explore,
meaning there is science to acupuncture.
There is science to why certain smells
do certain things to your brain.
Those are real things.
And if there are things that we can do
before we get to let's say
medication and diagnoses and DSM this,
we should all know about those things.
I think it should be a human right
for us to be educated
about how our mind is
connected to our body
and how that impacts our mental health.
So we talk to experts in
the field every episode
or people who are experts
in their own journey
and their own struggles.
And sometimes those
are famous celebrities,
but it is available on Spotify
or wherever you get podcasts
and we also do broadcast
it on my YouTube channel,
which has almost a million followers.
So we encourage people also to sign up
if you'd like to see me and Jonathan.
We wear matching outfits every episode.
- I didn't catch that
that you wear matching outfits.
No I mean it's a very important thing.
And I have to say that I
was one of these people,
you know, we grew up in a culture where,
you kind of take pride in
oh, I'm functional, I'm sane,
et cetera, et cetera and then you're like,
these are other people's problems.
And I think, as you know,
every family has a lot in it
that usually you try to hide
and not have transparent
to the rest of the world.
And I mentioned it on your podcast
and I think I've mentioned it here too,
is my first real glimpse personally
was about five years ago where I think
frankly because of stress
at work and other things,
I started getting
incredibly claustrophobic,
I wasn't sleeping as much as,
I found myself going for
runs at three in the morning
because that's all I could do
to get rid of some of my energy,
and that was the first
time that I realized
that I shouldn't just like identify myself
as a functional person,
that we all have, and it creeps up on you,
it creeps up on you,
it's like a frog in boiling water.
And so it's really important,
for me what I mentioned yesterday,
for me, meditation.
And when I meditated
almost out of desperation
to not get claustrophobic in planes,
which clearly I had to
travel a lot for my job,
it opened up a whole new world for me.
So not only did it help solve
the claustrophobia and the anxiety
and the panic I would get in small spaces,
but it helped open my life
in other really powerful, beautiful ways
that I would never have done
had I not experienced that.
So happy that you are taking this mantle,
people should be talking
about this because it,
when we talk about mental health,
people always talk about from
the deficit side of things,
but it can also add and
gives a space for it.
So in the time we have left,
and there's so much so many questions
that are coming up about
all all sorts of things,
maybe from Nich786,
"What are some challenges you faced
becoming a neuroscientist?
What advice do you have for people
who want to follow a path like yours?"
You mentioned a few of them,
but I'm sure there were others.
- Yeah I mean,
honestly being a woman
in a field that is typically
male can have its challenges.
There are women in situations
far far more challenging
than what I experienced
and what many women experience.
But I think it is definitely
something to acknowledge
that the standards for women
tend to be very limited in terms of,
there's a few ways that
people are often comfortable
with women being in the sciences.
And so that's something just to kind of,
that you have to keep in mind.
I think also, deciding when
and how to have children
was particularly challenging.
And not every woman wants to have children
or there are a lot of ways to be a mom
without physically giving birth,
but it's definitely a set of challenges
that I had to kind of plan and
time the best that I could.
And I'm not a great test taker
and there are exams required,
there was the GRE,
which was very challenging,
to get into grad school,
and then we had qualifying
exams our first year,
two of which I needed
to do remediation on,
which was humiliating,
but also just part of the process.
I was called into the head
of the department's office
after my first year and she said, "We",
you know, all of neuroscience,
"we're kind of surprised and disappointed
'cause you were an A student
and yet you did not do
well on your exams."
And I kind of hung my head,
it was definitely hard.
And I think that's also just
cause it wasn't something
that came naturally naturally
to me, that kind of thinking.
So those were,
you know, I cried in her office,
it was not a pretty moment,
but I made it through.
- I mean, were there moments
where you thought you
were gonna just give up
or was there a voice saying
no you're not gonna give up?
- Yeah, I mean I think
anyone who's done a PhD,
it's like literally people forget also,
I did a PhD when there
wasn't really computer access
to articles or information.
We had to physically go to the library,
which at UCLA, we call it the Stacks,
and it's like a 10 story building
and you would get a little card
that you would have to put cash on
so that you can make the copies
and you'd be in the middle of some article
and then you'd run out
of money on your card
and by the time you got back,
someone shelved the book
that you were working on.
So it was a lot of physical labor
and also formatting a 300 page
thesis is also no small feat.
And we also didn't have all the tools
that are now available to do that.
The formatting alone made me
want to not get my doctorate.
Like that was the level of
proficiency I felt I had
with that aspect.
So I know those sound silly
but when you've been doing
research for six years
and you're just trying to finish
and you have a newborn,
the last thing you want to be told
by the office where you submit
is that your margins are off on page three
and you have to start all
over with your formatting.
- I just can imagine the thoughts.
I mean I actually can't imagine
'cause one of my friends from college,
actually I've known him
from childhood, he was,
I got to know him,
he beat me the math competition,
so I'm like, I'm gonna
hang out with this guy.
He beat me in 10th grade
and then he actually ended
up being the first president,
like the COO and president of
Khan Academy when we started,
so very close friend of mine.
But I remember when,
and he, super smart guy,
but I remember, he had his first child
a year before I had mine or we had ours
and I remember one day he was just like,
his hair is all disheveled,
he's like, "Sal, I don't know,
everything else has been kind of easy.
I can crush tests."
I mean he is a good test taker.
He's like, "It's just been easy."
He was a triple major at MIT, it was easy.
He's like, "But this
child rearing, it's hard
and everyone does it.
How come everyone does it?
If it's so hard for me,
how can everyone else?"
And he's right.
But the fact that you were
doing that while getting a PhD-
- He's a total nerd, my first,
they're both kind of nerdy,
but my first born, he was literally,
he was raised on thesis.
- There might be something to that.
You know, people like play Mozart
while their kids are
like if you do a thesis,
if you're at the copying machine
while they're getting the radiation,
it might do something.
- Just as, maybe to finish off,
a lot of people asking a lot of questions,
your views of the future, 2021,
what are you looking forward to?
You have so many projects,
so many interests.
What do you kind of see as
the next phase of your life,
next 10 years say?
- Gosh, you know, I
hope to retire by then.
I'm just so tired.
You know, I'm 45 and
my kids are 12 and 15.
So in many ways,
my entire life is kind of centered around
where they are in their
academics and in their life,
like my younger one's
preparing for his bar mitzvah.
So I'm tutoring him for that.
My older son will likely be starting
online community college courses,
that's what a lot of
homeschool high schoolers do.
So I think of where they
will be in the next 10 years.
I definitely, I am working on a new show.
It's called "Call Me Cat",
and it's fun,
I'm having a really great time doing it.
So I'm hoping that we get
a second season of that.
And honestly, this podcast is really,
it's really my passion.
You know, it sounds so
pretentious, but it is,
it is my passion to
talk about mental health
and to be able to maybe
one day be able to advocate
on a larger DC level for
mental health access.
That's something I would
really, really love to see
as what I get to work on.
But honestly, I miss traveling and it's,
I'm very conservative I
guess when it comes to COVID,
as many scientists tend to be.
So I'm also really just kind of cautious
about what this year is gonna look like.
And I think a lot of people
don't understand the
importance of the vaccine.
I think a lot of people don't understand
the implications of not
getting the vaccine.
I've been very vocal about that.
I put out a YouTube video
about the importance of that.
So I'm kind of cautious about
what this year will look like
because it's been a long time
since I've been to a supermarket
and I'm ready to get back out there,
but just waiting.
- No, I definitely hear you.
I live with obviously my
wife and my mother-in-law.
My wife's a doctor,
and so she's gotten her vaccine now.
My mother-in-law just got her booster.
So I am now the major
risk factor in the house.
So I'm gonna see how
much they care about me.
- I'm sure it's not the first time
you've been the most dangerous
person in your house.
- That's right.
That's right.
I like that.
I'm glad you see that in me.
So Mayim, thank you so,
this was a, I could talk for hours
and I know everyone listening could hear
and listen to your wisdom for hours,
but thank you so much for joining
and I hope in that 10 years,
and I'm serious, we should explore
a little bit of science
education one way or the other.
- I would absolutely love that
and again, my children
would lose their mind.
- Let's do it.
All right, well Mayim Bialik,
thank you so much for joining us.
This was a real treat.
- Thank you so much, Sal.
- So thanks everyone for joining.
Hopefully you found that,
I've only had a few times,
I've got the privilege of
hanging out with Mayim,
but she just has incredible energy
and I think it's very powerful
when you can see someone
who can throw across so many genres
and break so many different
types of stereotypes.
So hopefully you enjoyed
that as much as I did.
So thank you for joining.
I know I'm doing these a
little bit more sporadically
than I was doing earlier this year
but we look forward to see you soon.
I'm gonna go on a little
bit of a vacation next week
and then the week after
we will back be back on this live stream.
So thanks everyone for joining
and have a good weekend.